okay another day another city today
we are in nagasaki it's uh
colder today outside so we're in our
hoodies and jackets ready to go we had
breakfast delivered to our room because
we want to just get off the boat
and explore the city quickly so here we
go
so so far everybody's been super helpful
and welcoming everybody says
welcome and asking questions we're at
the
area here and they're all selling
various arts and crafts and
local stuff and then there's a table
here of volunteers who
are just answering questions and giving
you maps and just being super helpful
and friendly
okay well we're gonna go explore
nagasaki
first stop in nagasaki basically like
all of our cities
is starbucks across the street
so i'm at the starbucks here and
we finally have some internet which is
great haven't been able to get gmail or
facebook or anything because
being in china they don't allow those
sites
and what's interesting is here at the
bar where you get your straws and
everything they also have
a sink where you have a faucet and soap
if you want to wash your hands
it's pretty cool
so the one thing i forgot about japan is
that nobody really uh
eats or drinks on the streets walking on
the subway
the reasoning and if you're drinking
something yummy like a
starbucks frappuccino uh you're gonna
make other people jealous
and so you don't want to make them
jealous so it's better not to not to
drink
and as a result because nobody eats or
drinks on the streets there's no garbage
cans
because there's nothing to throw away
and so we uh nina's got her glass here
that she's finished but there's no
garbage can to throw it away we're just
about to enter our first temple
and take a look around uh but first we
try to find a garbage can for nina
so this place was built in the 1600s and
is uh the oldest temple in nagasaki
all of the instructions are in japanese
so we don't
really know about much of the stuff but
we're gonna go on a little
tour and see what we can find
very traditional architecture which is
cool because all the stuff we've seen
has been
pretty modern yeah going to the big
cities you're going to get all the
modern stuff
okay we're going to another temple this
one is called daikoji
so everybody's super friendly here and
they always say hi to you as you go in
i love the vending machines here in
japan they've got this one here
uh it says boss and they got tommy lee
jones and i guess some japanese guy
and on the side it says
boss coffee suntory boss is the boss of
them all since 1992.
it's amazing going to our third and last
temple of the day
hoshinji temple let's go explore this
bell was forged in china in 14
1438 and remains as the oldest temple
bell nagasaki
extremely unusual in its design it is
among the many temple bells presently
existing in nagasaki
that's an old bell
this is the oldest bridge in nagasaki
and has been designated as
a important cultural asset
so i guess it's protected by the
government it's just covering this
little tiny stream
oh look it's nina what are you doing
here
fancy meeting a girl like you
so we're hungry and we're having our
first meal here in nagasaki
and we found this local place that has
the smallest chairs of all time
at home i love having i love having the
chicken katsu
and sushi and danbury and so we're
excited to try the local food here to
see how they make
japan get authentic even though uh i
hope
it's pretty good so we'll see how it
matches it here's another sink so it's
cool at all the places where you eat you
have an option
just out in public to wash your hands
quickly before eating
so i'm having the pork curry it smells
so good
i want to eat it right now
oh and here's nina's what did you get
again
it's the um belly pork belly i think
it's so
pork belly i'm not sure
cheers
yummy ah yeah it's so good
this is gonna go fast this is like two
minutes later
mine's almost gone nina has an empty
bowl
what do you think i'm happy if nina's
happy then i'm happy
okay so we're at the japanese department
store and these stores are awesome where
the ground floor is like a supermarket
and then as you go up to higher floors
it's clothing
and houseware and basically everything
you need in one store
nina wanted to have some snacks so what
do we buy here
i don't know oh
continuing on down the streets of
nagasaki exploring the shops and markets
these are the pedestrian streets what is
that i don't know nina is always very
excited by food
everybody's pretty friendly and i like
these pedestrian-only
streets that you can walk down and enjoy
it's nice that everything's open perfect
nina size evan would have to duck
but his perfect nina size
squid head okay i don't need to eat this
stuff
we made another purchase at the under
actually it's not even on the ground
it's just covered mall let's see we
bought what'd you buy nina
evan has bought nothing yet but it's
okay look at these stores they're so
bright and crazy anyway okay sorry
two different kind of lashes false
lashes
false lashes okay what's difference
between the ones these ones and what you
have now
um those ones are better too they're
very light
then i don't feel it when i have it on
okay but the other one that i brought
it's heavy you can feel it okay anyways
so those are super light and you don't
feel it
yeah okay and i also got these blue
what's that
for the lashes oh okay oh you glue it on
okay so you're happy with the glue
okay good i'm and i am learning about
eyelashes and glue and so now is
everybody in believe nation we are all
learning about
eyelashes and glue together
all right let's keep shopping what do we
buy now
especially for women especially for
women i know i haven't got anything
where's the bottle thing oh we got some
bras all right
it's called japanese cotton towel
you wrap with uh you put the towel in
the middle and then you wrap it
you wrap the the bottle and you tie it
to the top
and it's like a handle it's for any like
drinking bottle yep any drinking water
all right okay that's cool right okay
more shopping
here we go for nina hey you happy yeah
okay good a very good point i think we
need to get it on camera
what's the good point um
hold on we haven't seen a unicorn
unicorn
unicorn unicorn in um
japan unique clothes
you should say i like the i like the
unicorn part that was that was fantastic
no no no that's that's a winner for sure
okay we're getting hungry it's lunch
time so we're gonna go to a
traditional japanese restaurant get some
food
they all have their menus displayed on
the outside with um
pictures what are you gonna get
um i don't know
not exactly sure what we ordered two
are you sure we ordered we got two ramen
and we got some beer
some bits out okay oh some yeah that's
chinese whatever okay try it no
you try first i wanna get a reaction
you're the big beer drinker in the
family
oh that's it's light
oh yeah it's nice time to eat so we both
have ramen
i have uh corn butter and
a bunch of vegetables and nina has their
house dish
which is seafood i think it was clams
and scallops
okay we're just leaving the restaurant
i'm feeling good that was a yummy meal
uh the toilet got angry at me
as i walked into the washroom the first
seat lifted up and
you know i got to lift up the second
seat and and i lifted it up slowly and
it started beeping at me angrily and
then started lifting up automatically
then i discovered to the left that there
were buttons that did all of that stuff
so uh it takes a few minutes to figure
out the japanese washrooms but
but they're fun i was thinking about
bringing the camera in but felt uh
no that felt wrong i mean we did look at
nina's bras
next we're going to uh the train station
area which is supposed to have
local oops whoa son local arts and
crafts and
fun stuff so we'll see what's there and
continue on our journey
yeah we're walking let's go
so this is the train station and
attached to it
is some shops
because we haven't done enough shopping
yet right nina maybe
all right we bought something else and
every time we checked out
they they look at nina and they start
speaking in japanese
and they don't understand why she
doesn't speak japanese too so they must
think she's japanese
what do we buy this time babe mooji
and you bought tweezers okay tweezers
and the mask and the last well not a
five mask five masks sensitive skin
that's it and we're off
more shopping to do we're walking the
streets of nagasaki and
we made a very important and exciting
discovery
what is it babe uniqlo uniqlo
up ahead let's go check it out authentic
in japan
okay we're down to our last 800 yen
which is about 10 bucks or so nina's
feeling a coke
so we're gonna use one of these fancy
vending machines okay so pop it in here
we go
a little silver one that's a hundred
okay and then then all these gold ones
are tens
oh it doesn't tank what do you mean it
doesn't take it doesn't take five
oh i thought i'd be getting rid of my
change and instead i now have tons more
changes
here we are walking back to our boat sun
is about to go down
the sapphire princess and we're gonna go
down
and have a nap okay we came back on
board
had a quick shower lay down and then
realized oh
it's dinner time we're thinking we
should get some snacks and then look at
the clock he's like oh we should go get
some dinner
so we're gonna eat another tasty meal
hopefully and then
and then come back and really relax
before going out to go dancing
oh and nina is wearing her new bra today
oh you can kind of see the white through
the back how does it feel babe
it's good it's light i don't feel it on
my shoulders see yeah
okay more bra shopping tomorrow but
first dinner time
we were overwhelmed at the generosity
and kindness of the japanese people
everybody's really welcoming
and uh and helpful and
as a sign of respect what they did was
we're just about to leave and they have
a drumming crew
giving us a send off just to say
basically thank you for coming and have
a safe
trip off so overall huge fan of the
japanese people and
we're probably gonna make a comeback
visit
if you want the real goods i share my
best advice for entrepreneurs every week
in my newsletter
click the link below to check it out
it's free
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com
and i want to say evan carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun
inspiring and it's the only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to
period